Michael Douglas joining us he's in the
movie ant-man and the wasp it's theaters
July 6th what did you say to Dale jr.
when he saw I said your luck on the book
tour you know I followed his and
certainly his father's career a lot I am
actually a Formula one fan I mean I
watched NASCAR a little bit but I'm a
big Formula one fan for the last you
know 30 years and a car geek I'm a car
geek as mentioned earlier I started off
I was in a hotrod Club in Westport
Connecticut the down shifters I had a 47
mercury with a model a ax on the back so
it was sort of slanted used to call it
the ruptured duck was my was my car I
love that were you tough guy
oh no I pretended it'd be tough to be a
tough guy and was born let's see if I
was a down shifters I was wearing my
jacket I probably be in the back of the
pack but then I was really fortunate in
one of my actually my first movie ever
did call Adam at 6:00 a.m.
Steve McQueen was my producer and in the
picture I got to drive I got paid like
nothing for it I you think $3,000 for
three months worth this 1969 and in the
movie I drove this tangerine orange
Porsche and that'll tangerine orange
color we used to drive and I finished
the picture and I said goodbye to Steve
and he held up a pair of keys for me oh
boy and he said here you go and I was
really really touched by that and
there's a result I kind of befriended
Steven he was very nice to me and he was
preparing for Lamont so he used to go
out to Willow Springs track outside on
the weekends and was driving rich again
Thurs 908 Porsche and he was really fast
he was a quarter of a second off off the
track record and so spending time with
him out there I then got into the Jim
Russell driving school which took like
Formula F's and taught you to drive and
so I drew the Southern California
circuit for a while driving racing
formula F's until I crashed and then I
realized this is a
is not a weekend sport you know this is
the more often
yeah something more dangerous being an
actor Yeah right
well it went what's reaction when you
now you're East Coast guy but what do
you get walking the streets what do
people say - what are you keep moving I
don't wait you know I get a lot you know
because if you keep moving and keep
walking that's the secret don't stop
okay you can hear afterwards they go
Mike Mike downed all that weed is good
that's probably the one I get more than
anything else when you sold that line in
a script did did it resonate with you
that what greed is good was gonna mean
to Gordon Gekko and Wall Street and know
that whole part was I mean I was the bad
guys I was I was the villain it's always
shocked me how many people on Wall
Street who say oh man you're the reason
I became I said I went to jail man I
went to jail like we've we rooted for
you and I don't know why we rooted for
this I had nice clothes that's all I was
mean I had really nice clothes should
thank my costume designer and a nice
wife and a nice girl and money and I
lied and I cheated and then that was it
so it's always made me a little
disturbed that people just just love
that character as much as they did but
Kevin Costner talked about Field of
Dreams where he said that that line do
you want to have a catch with his dad
and he said I saw that and realized that
I'm the the movie is built around that
line and I was wondering about that with
Wall Street it feels like greed is good
the movies built around that line
whether that was by design or not it
feels like yeah but it was it was Oliver
Stone wrote wrote a great screenplay a
great script and Gordon Gekko had a lot
to say in it and greed as good was a
line inside of a very long monologue
that he gave at a shareholders meeting
but she incorporated the US of A
a lot of other things and so yeah but it
did end up standing out that was the
clip of that speech they said you used
more than any other when you see that
character and the hair and that the way
you look and I you know I as rumor has
it that it was based off Pat Riley Pat
is a dear friend of mine it wasn't based
off Riley's look or did well off you
know no I had no I was looking at it was
the last decision you know the the
Wardrobe it always was tied in with a
lot a designer here in Wall Street and
everything else and the character's name
was a gecko you know and I am Pat and I
was a close friend and I looked at Patsy
greased hair and that was at the last
decision I got closer I said yeah I'm
gonna go for it so I did steal from Pat
and it was very effective the suspenders
you know the whole they look at that guy
right there we get we got this picture
in her at the Pat doesn't were spenders
no no who is that guy right there when
you look at him well it's a character
you know you make you make in there were
two or three there were two or three
which shall go unnamed big-time players
on Wall Street that I incorporated some
of their elements having having met some
of them and then you know what your role
is in the part and you try to - you know
personify and create this Gordon Gekko
villain how do I get your attention with
the script nowadays well you have to
have it come through I can't look at
unsolicited material but when you see
something that is handed to you what is
gonna is it dramas a being a bad guy is
if it's a good movie if I read this trip
I never worry about a part I'm just I
just want to be in good movies and
sometimes you know sometimes you get a
good part
or sometimes Sharon Stone gets the good
part you know so you just I want I read
a script and you know I produce a lot so
I'm I'm used to working on scripts and
structured all of that and so I just try
to find a good script I'm emotionally
move either makes me laugh
you know I'm scared gorilla whatever it
is whatever the emotion is and then I'll
put it down and then if it sticks with
me then I go back and I break you down I
structurally break it down and I see if
it really works that I wasn't just
seduced by the words on the page but I
can structurally see that the whole
piece makes sense and that's usually the
process but are you looking at it can
you look at it as in through a
producer's lens and there's an actor's I
know I I even as an actor because of the
producing experience I look at it as a
producer so I think in that's one things
that helps me as an actor because I know
that the only thing that matters I don't
want to be good in a bad movie I want to
be good in a good movie yeah and if I
got a smaller part or anything else and
I want everybody else to be good I
wanted to be as best as they can you
know here's some of these actors
insecure or trying to mess up other
actors no man I always embrace everybody
encouraged everybody to be as good as
they can make it an environment a
working relationship that's just as good
as it possibly can so everybody's doing
their best work you know you've made it
tough for guys to go to movies with some
of your roles there you know that sounds
like you're talking about fatal
attraction a disclosure disclosure
well disclosure I mentioned that when
I've been been lucky in this meet to
movement that they haven't jumped on me
for disclosure how would they know I
don't know that would go over too well
where a female boss was harassing a man
you know but not go over to L fatal
attraction was a was just a classic
story the worst what if situation of
having a an affair and I must say I had
a lot of my friends say well thanks
thanks a lot movie though Michael the
best was I think was where I was doing
interviews that moved for France in
France eBay you know we all had me
this is nothing it was a huge hit in
France every wife every French wife
dragged their husband not to see that
movie enough was there any part like
Basic Instinct mm-hmm when you read that
when you see that when Sharon Stone
comes in like at what point did you go
uh oh this I mean not oh but we're onto
something here
like this is gonna be big well I went
when we were casting it I was working I
really was actively involved it was
early 1990s and I wanted to do a slam
dance movie I just it was a very
conservative time and I was looking for
a real slam dance movie and Paul
Verhoeven wonderful director and so we
we found this wonderful script but we
had a cast cast the lady and Paul is a
dutch director and he's a little in your
face directly and he was having a little
problem with the casting because a lot
of times you would go to all these
actresses yeah they'll be like noodley
huh there's a lot of nudity that's it
Paul easy easy
nudity you tell him something else it's
a good picture every nudity and then you
know so we were having trouble casting
it and then I was in Europe and then he
sent me a tape of an audition he did
with Sharon Stone and it's what movies
are all about his proper casting and you
saw this tape with a Wow she'd be great
and the rest is history
we're talking to Michael Douglas ant-man
and the wasp it's theaters July 6th what
attracted you to dr. Pym well this is a
sequel the original one was ant-man and
I have never done one of these
green-screen CGI movies you know my
career almost every movie I've done has
been contemporary and just psychological
thrillers character driven I've never
done one of these so I was just really
excited about the chance to do them and
it's just a wild trip I mean I have a
whole new appreciation about acting when
there's nothing there I mean you just
got green walls
and they have a little bit on the floor
and they tell you you know I this is
coming in from the right or look up here
on the left and you think and you really
feel like an idiot you know but you you
trust your director and and they they
you trust the angles that you're looking
and so when you're doing it you really
don't know how it's working out so I
just saw Ant Man of the wasp the night
before in LA we had a big Hollywood
premiere blocked off Hollywood Boulevard
like old fashioned it was so cool and
it's great it's absolute but I used that
to act when you're not acting with
somebody it is it's it's hard I mean III
was humbled and had a whole new
appreciation I mean saying that once you
kind of get into the thick of things I
mean who doesn't want to get small so it
was amazing and to see how they they tie
it all together and when we were
shooting the picture down in Atlanta and
I'd go from you know set to set because
just once it has just the actors like
you and I are here another set would
have our stunt doubles doing their stuff
another one but having the CGI and then
finer some guys do little tiny miniature
work with all this stuff and everything
and you know you never see it all
together so I'm really happy about it
and the other thing that really came
home to me is this wonderful response is
coming in is you know then this sort of
a this device of time and in the world
in our country everything seems to be
fragmented everybody's polarized and
arguing a big movie like this brings
everybody together and the idea that
this picture is showing around the world
reminds you in 40 different languages
people are laughing pretty amazing it
really reminds me of the joy and
appreciation of movies and the movie
industry and how what we do
and and how we export it and how it
brings together so many people comedy
versus drama what's tougher comedies
much much tougher I mean to think about
your friends I don't we all cherish a
funny friend you know and we got enough
friends that matter serious huh it's
that guy who's funny I don't know why it
doesn't get the attention acknowledged
better to ask your time I've been
fortunate enough where I've tried on
four or five pictures to do some comedy
dinner picture Romancing the Stone years
ago and we did I like a a dark comedy
picture called the War of the Roses
which we did a while ago one of the
reasons I want to do ant-man and the
wasp was to do comedy and it's it's it's
very difficult the least of which is no
audience so you don't know you know you
go to anything like that and it's out
there you don't get that you're gonna
you get a silent soundstage sort of
dreaming ah what's this gonna sound like
six months from now you know when they
put it all together
I love falling down to thank you falling
down I'm the bad guy
yeah but that was a good I get that line
lat oh you look bad do you like being
the bad guy well yeah I mean being the
bad guy she's here being the best being
easier me being the villain has done
more I mean everybody's acting career
my father Kirk did like about six
pictures is the sensitive young man
before I did a picture called champion
nineteen fifty are nominated for Academy
Award played a nasty-ass boxer and and
was really good I went a long way early
or my career before I did Wall Street
and got an Oscar and sort of pay
attention and it's interesting because I
look back and when we were producing One
Flew Over the Cuckoo's Nest and we're
trying to find the actress to play nurse
ratchet we couldn't find an actress to
do it they all turned it down because at
that moment in the women's movement no
woman wanted to be a villain you didn't
want to be a villain here was this
fabulous part we had five major
actresses
turn it down before we found Louise
Fletcher who went on to win the Oscar
for Best Actor ratchet right what's Jack
the original guy that you wanted Nikhil
no Jai we actually you have to remember
back then Jack had done like Easy Rider
five Easy Pieces
he had more the image of sort of the
intellectual the guy he was a little bit
of a sensitive young man with humor so
we had going after Gene Hackman for four
RP McMurphy was going after Marlon
Brando for for it you know and bad it
didn't work and then a director Hal
Ashby showed me up the picture he did
was called the last detail where Jack
was playing a career Navy officer that
was the first time he saw some other the
gravitas in the bulk in the size and did
you know immediately we knew immediately
when we got up there wasn't just Jack we
knew because we had to wait for him for
a while and we spent an inordinate
amount of time casting the picture and
if you look at that pictures probably
one of those beautifully cast films in
terms that all those patients are very
and he was in there and Christopher
Lloyd and all of them so we knew we knew
he had something special I couldn't tell
you what but it was it was riveting when
you used to watch the dailies and you
did you room with DeVito I did Danny was
my roommate here in New York when I
first came to the city as an actor what
were you guys like going to casting you
know whatever when you're all we hang
out a lot together it was I mean we you
know it's tough to tell all the stories
[Laughter]
we had it we had a good time we had a
good time he was a good roommate I could
just imagine you two walking into a bar
we had yeah we had we had a good time I
know I know that your golf tougher
golfing or acting Oh coffee
I got golfing I mean I I mean III have
continuities in my acting when I'm
golfing I know who's showing up okay you
know I mean I know I'm gonna go work in
the morning I got that part you know
what you're doing yeah you know I know
when I'm you know and that's what you
pop in and you're a good good golfer and
you know for me it's tempo you know and
I've really gotta count on my tempo
being there and I start getting fast
troubling and getting short snapping
well in getting short it's it's you know
it makes you look really embarrassing
don't you think Arnold Palmer looked
like a movie star like when he was young
and he had the the tight shirts and
smoking heaters and I guess he looked
yeah yes so I mean his swing sure was
Sam Snead it wasn't glamorous yes I'm
Sunita I mean you see all every club ego
do you see those those 80s with a turn
he had if I said you could be Jack
Nicklaus or you could have your career
oh man that's a tough call that's a
really tough call that Jack Nicklaus yes
I could have Jack Nicklaus I could have
more majors but in the history of golf
yes I gotta go guys whenever we have in
somebody big-time I always say to my
guys the Danette you get they get
together for one question okay gather
for one yeah that's it that's all they
got all the guys would one question may
you run it yes I hear Michael is for
them and wanna yeah I know there's your
show yes okay Paulie is the designated
speaker here the one question that the
Dennett's have collaborated on for
Michael Douglas is Dan this is Michael
Douglas who you may have to give us a 1a
but mr. Douglas the shirt the horizontal
striped shirt you wore in Wall Street
did you get to keep it
yes I did I keep all of my wardrobes
there were my archives you can't wear it
the shirt was a big deal this shirt was
a very big deal set up set a whole
fashion tone for for a lot of people so
it's just stored away it's stored away
that's it okay okay you guys got one a
here one effort see I just always wanted
to know from fatal attraction because
that move
that line I'm not gonna be ignored he
does that to me all the time when I
ignore him I just want to make sure we
check the stove Michael when I come in
with fritzy visceral I remember that
scene when I come back home to my
apartment and I hear her voice talking
to my wife in the apartment and she was
looking and she's looking to buy the
apartment be she's about to have a baby
she's pregnant just the setup of that
yeah we're we're in your head on what
you're thinking as you hear Glenn Close
and you just know how what else is going
to end here yeah no it was a ok one more
that's it
McLovin this one might get you in
trouble Dan are you allowed to answer
this question are you in Avengers 4 I'm
not allowed to answer that College
forget it is if I startled my mouth
there's a blowgun the side of my neck
for Marvel films that comes in and gets
it nobody wants to know if I'm a Jets
fan a Jets fan oh you are yeah I am I
root because of Pat Riley I'm support to
Miami Heat are you a die-hard Jets fan
yeah well I started out in you know way
back from the beginning of my life as a
Giants fan but I also was under the
undelete the aura of Joe Namath and no
one were you in when they won Super Bowl
three I was only love for what year was
Abbott 60 69 69 I was 25 but were you a
five were you a Jets fan then when they
won and you were Giants fan growing up
obviously I was a Giants fan growing up
and that's sort of that that year and
him calling it sort of moved me over
what if you could be Jack Nicklaus or
Joe Namath Jack Nicklaus okay so let's
joke are we good we're all good so we
don't know if he's in adventure it for
McLovin I have some quantum realm
questions to me a million questions
subatomic stuff but you guys would not
understand only me and Michael would
Aunt May
the wasp its theaters July 6th thank you
for stopping by thank you so much it's
tradition for more Dan Patrick show to
the audience channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]